Y esa alianza
que inicia en el legislativo
se convierte en una alianza
electoral en 2021,
en 22 23 y hoy felizmente llegamos a este 2 024.
¿Pero por qué nos ha ido tan bien?
Porque fue una alianza que no se hizo
a partir de intereses oscuros,
nada de principios
y de valores de un proyecto compartido de nación,
a diferencia
de las alianzas que se hacen en el PRI y el pan,
que son a cambio de cargos,
de puestos, de notarías,
de oficinas, de recaudación
de corrupción.
Por eso celebro también que el partido verde haya
participado en el proceso
de la encuesta para seleccionar
a nuestra candidata y felicito
a nuestro querido
amigo
el senador rebelde
Manuel Velasco